welcome back to et here in nashville
with my guest co-host
mr bobby bones bobby are you a big judge
judy fan i feel like who isn't right i
think everyone loves judge judy yeah you
can't not love judge judy wait you were
at her house recently right i was and
she's just amazing and so feisty i love
it but judy's also gearing up for a new
chapter
in her career but not before giving e.t
an exclusive glimpse into her life
in the sunshine state judge judy always
great to see you thank you for inviting
e.t to your home here in florida
it is stunning how long have you and
your family retreated here to this spot
we've been in naples since 1999. as soon
as i could afford it i moved to naples
i want you to start banging your head on
the table and don't stop until i tell
you
now worth an estimated 440 million
dollars
it's fair to say judge judy is living
her best life
with pretty much the sweetest schedule
in hollywood you're not supposed to
speak unless i'm looking at you
it's not a nine to five monday through
friday job
she works 52 days a year and gets paid
47
million dollars now the feisty iconic
courtroom diva
tells me why season 25 will be your last
25 years is a good
round number there's something
spectacular about a quarter of a century
cbs had acquired my library
so i have a new adventure and i'd like
to work i've always worked
retirement is not in the 78 year old's
vocabulary
while cbs will continue to air judge
judy reruns
ms shineland will preside over a new
amazon imdb
tv series judy justice how will this new
show
venture away from what you've done for
the past 25 years i would tell you but
then i'd have to kill you oh come on
come on give me a little something you
can't change that much of court
a seat you can add some things to
that to make it more visually
interesting and sometimes more realistic
which is what we will do how do you feel
like your judging style
has evolved over the years i don't think
my
style has changed my face has changed a
little bit
my hairstyle has changed a little bit
did you think that ponytail would create
such a fuss amongst fans didn't some
older woman who changes her hair i
didn't think people
watched that carefully what i looked
like after what was fun
is there one letter for the fan that has
been particularly memorable to you
i told my crew early on do not give me
bad letters
over 25 days i have never gotten a bad
do you ever go back and watch some of
your vintage shows
sometimes you know late at night if we
don't want to watch the news anymore i'd
rather watch myself
that's amazing
you